ce qui est mal temps c'est tout au plus
mais ce que je suis mais ce rigoler
acsta glider tout de suite et vous
mettez ce que vous pensez de jean michel
maire en sniper les bac 2 vous avez une
phobie bou hadjar et les oiseaux les
plumes d'oiseaux les plus beaux oiseaux
à tous chants d'oiseaux on n'arrivait
pas tu change la donne peut pas vous
préparer un petit peu plus fort je ne
peux pas toucher oiseaux d'accord mais
quand même
eh ben je sais pas d'où ça vient mais
une fois yankees rentrer chez moi d'être
comme on l'a fait ça sans déconner c'est
la cuite hutteau phobie financer
l'ornitho l'avenant oui et loti me
regarde avec ça c'est l'ornitho faut oui
ça veut dire ça veut dire majorettes tu
pourrais pas de patron plume dont par
exemple
alors et alors c'est le problème c'est
qu'il a la place de jean luc lemoine
[Rires]
qu'on a aujourd'hui
voilà je vous le dis on va lui dire un
mot d'ailleurs d'accord qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors est ce que j'aurai pas que
la transition la succession salle avait
vite comme ça que jean luc n'a pas
démérité du tout donc le 4 il a fait
avec le talon qui dit qu'il avait fait
avec les moyens du bord je suis sur son
téléphone va sonner bien accrocher les
jambes à ce très fort jean-luc on t'aime
la famille de son téléphone va sonner
des demandes ce qui sera là demain ça
passe c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui vous
ces mêmes et en plus vous n'êtes même
pas considéré comme twitter c'est juste
que j'avais envie que géraldine soit en
face de vous tout simplement de seconde
alors bon c'est quand votre phobie le
boulot de tout ça je voudrais pas bosser
ah ouais bah j'ai jamais jamais jamais
j'ai jamais tellement essayons donc je
ne sais pas trop si j'aimerais ou pas
mais le peu que j'ai fait le peu que
j'ai bossé m'a pas donné envie de
persévérer dans cette voie donc je pense
que c'est une sorte de folie mais pas
remboursés par la sécurité sociale mais
j'aime pas ça vous le savez toute façon
j'ai prouvé ma phobie j'ai la phobie des
pieds je sais pas comment ça s'appelle
allait bien c'est le fils et l'opac de
l'auf a horreur de ça touche avec les
pays hormis les pieds des bébés deux
jours de montage est encore petit ben
ouais je ne déteste ça et les deux
chaînes je ne peux pas le prendre mais
le mien oui mais les urnes alors qu'il
ya dans les pieds avec des verrues des
oignons détail peur mais ma passion
c'est le play dans les pieds de jean
michel maire pense à des pieds les plus
horribles qu'on connaisse au moins
quatre mois je t'aime bien michel ça
vous dérange pas les pieds mais du coup
ça me dérange
pourquoi n'ont-ils de vie des pauvres je
suis hanté le mob quoi antelme aux
folles entre mendient j'ai la phobie des
verts non verts luisants la mise en
disant je suis allée acheter une pomme
monsieur le primeur je les suivais
croquer même le seul gars de son âge et
du cheveu acheter une poche
je descends je vais chez le primeur
as-tu besoin de quelque chose pour la
ratatouille de ce soir là haut je
l'apprends gelé suis-je la fraude
blackrock
elle a un énorme revers de 4 cm il est
passé et je me suis qu'il avait une
drôle de tête le vert ben je venais de
bouffer sa wii depuis en était le maire
s'entête t elle s'entête à le dire tu as
des amis dans le noir par exemple
quoi quoi la vie dans le noir les verts
aux mères n'est pas et n'a peur chez
vous et vous nous envoyez des trucs que
j'aime pas le boulot est bien autrement
pourquoi keskar jeb bush au contraire
oui mais le boulot ici c'est pour vous
c'est un boulot ici alors c'est vrai ça
fait huit ans nous plaisir je voulais
souvent écrit d'ailleurs mais jamais
répondu mais ça me plaisait mais les
clowns blancs j'ai la terreur des clowns
blancs ouais parce qu'en plus je sais
jamais si c'est des clowns blancs qu'on
a maquillé ou s'ils sont vraiment des
clowns blancs et vous croyez le bien des
messes clown blanc oui ça veut dire
genre yahia l'obstétricien oui je laisse
cette akrout blanc et le gris nez avec
cannes et en os tout ça le petit
directeur met toujours du mal à passer
angèle un quoi les chaussures ont du mal
à passer
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est gbagbo qui met pas quand une femme
se des choses il me semble qu'un jour je
vous ai entendu dire à une chroniqueuse
armée terme et et chaussures je déteste
cinéma le temps on se tourne je peux
plus ce match et ce qui l'est moins ce
que je suis mais ce rigoler à steinbach
tout de suite et vous mettez ce que vous
pensez de jean michel maire en sniper
non mais c'est vrai que non j'ai c'est
que c'est caroline ithurbide elle vaut
absolument avec pieds nus sur touche à
tout à chaque fois lauréat partout elle
éleva type de votre pays donc je dis
chance sur toi chanceux toi j'aime bien
et sont jointes aux séries je suis à
l'ancienne donc j'aime bien voilà côtoyé
je vous écoute
voyez je vous écoute merci oui alors
sinon oui moi j'ai alors moi j'avais la
hantise est née des cauchemars d'enfants
de me retrouver nue dans une foule n'en
risque pas associée par la foule
surtout ne s'étaient pas entendus mais
je pense que ça vient aussi le cauchemar
d'un appel - là vous vous trouvez
j'ai fait un bon début de rentrée à mon
avis d'admission des bonnettes bon mais
que deux indices vraiment note que sans
déconner
non non c'est pas
[Musique]